I'll close out with a king under sting
it CEO Brendan Chan Nick cat mr. Lacey
what's good it's a beautiful day in West
Virginia I'm talking Charleston West my
god Virginia beautiful do you King or do
you sting the idea about being on one of
these flights future flights that are
gonna potentially colonize Mars do you
King or do sting is I hear that Mars
rides are just one way ain't coming back
so appreciate you guys Podcast rocks
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz mr. blue
eyes [ __ ] Austin well Mars same thing
like I'm doing with us and I'm we go
ahead and let Brogan go out there first
tell me the lay of the land then I'll
follow up you feel me Brogan's can go to
Mars go ahead you have to admit there's
no doubt that Rogan would go to Mars if
they got any way to do it
oh I might get a text like hey Doug
change the plans I went to decide to go
to Mars all right
hey real quick I bought Mars so we're
doing the comments tour in Mars man you
down you have to get your boron levels
check should be cool man I got I hired a
doctor
[Laughter]
this dude's been a bust and Timberlake
over here and so we get him a boyband
check out them brows - this guy is mixed
it's the most light-skinned black dude
I've ever even seen do you want to be
the little spoon he also talked for like
three minutes trying to convince you
guys to come to Nashville so the
Nashville yeah I just made it shorter
but yeah he's just like we're we're open
we got comedy in Nashville yeah but he's
in West Virginia I thought but he does
real estate I guess
maybe I don't know maybe he talked for
something about for three minutes I
don't know I cut it off but okay right
someone was convincing us to go in
Nashville said no state income tax and
stuff yeah he's right I'm gonna look in
a couple weeks over there I think we'll
just get together and do King mustaine
yeah figure it out yeah I think it'd be
cool I just yeah someone I think I don't
know if I can be in this place anymore
sometimes it just feels brother tough
it's just scary yeah I don't know about
all going to Mars [ __ ] that noise yeah
yeah but again I could be talked into it
well this young man was asking about um
what's the taxes like on Mars you feel
me I'm bad high as hell yeah build a
[ __ ] society yeah well that one man
did it and he bought them vegetables
member Matt Damon good point
you know those dope ass SUVs and [ __ ]
rolling around Mars
they took his own [ __ ] made potatoes out
of it that was cool and then he won the
Golden Globe for Best Comedy for that
drama this is low year but yeah a wee
little for Dakar on Mars Rogan but it
won't be the only way to borrow the car
from him all we have like just an uber
day he'd be our bird driver yeah be like
a 140 million dollar vehicle it'd be
it'd be him and Elon Musk rover by Tesla
yeah yeah telega be boring as [ __ ] over
there after a while it'd be cool for a -
I bet three days bro by day four I'd be
like I'll go anywhere that's fair
you know I bet it would just get cuz
you're all gonna be in the same little
place you're not gonna have a big place
on Mars probably cuz I bet it the square
footages can't be cheap half a mil per
foot you know no restaurants that's why
you'd open up the barbecue spot on Mars
yeah out of this world
Lacey do your recipes need gravity to do
your recipes need gravity bro that's the
first thing you gotta bring a lot of
sugar with you yeah where are you gonna
get the ribs yes
you got a deer if something that's been
living here we don't know what the wild
life's like up there yeah bro you don't
have any plan I'm not invested in this
barbecue joint anymore I'm gonna reopen
that email about that sinaloa zoo we got
says yeah that's a good real tasty right
now that looks like a better business
opportunity Chappelle yeah now what if
you had a barbecue truck done member
that's rug but if you did a truck you
know no you could promote on food truck
Diaries and then it has to be pretty
fire food though you can't put the car
before the truck yeah come on just can't
have anyone on the show man there's two
ways to get on that show you either buy
the truck or you fight that guy that
Brendan mr. Larkin or whatever Justin
there John occurred fight Johnny Curtis
you get on the show huh yourself man God
YouTube is gonna be your trainer Doug
YouTube is my trainer oh my god I mean
YouTube what was this guy's question I
can you remember colonizing Mars king
under stinging well Jamis state yeah I
don't stop there forever no it still
might be better in LA right now do they
have a Korean space program as Korea has
made filming yeah no I don't they don't
I have no idea
oh so I didn't know if you governor
[ __ ] Newsome's gonna be up there as
well you know what it seemed like space
cuz it's awesome Russia to America
isn't it interesting you know it's such
a is it like oh do you think it's been
like a white thing trying to get to
space cuz it's interesting that other
countries are like dude this is [ __ ]
like y'all have smart I don't know 101
things to go to like a different
countries like I want to go to
Manchester
we'll buy a ticket Jesus man we talked
about Mars lacy came to get a [ __ ]
together for this food truck yeah you
can make a shitty barbecue sauce give me
a million ideas here man [ __ ] space for
you Chappelle's you like man everybody
let's go to Mars I don't want to go to
Manchester everybody trying it to Mars
I'm trying go to Burbank colonize Mars
ping it people want to go yeah people
are feeling like [ __ ] go then you know I
thought it was in seeking Louie keys in
louis c.k special the new one that's on
just on the internet it's great he talks
about he's like yeah and you know I just
I had a lot of bad publicity going on
and I wanted to go somewhere he goes the
problem is you every place you pick is
still on earth he goes he goes I really
wanted to go to another planet he's like
I literally remember getting on the
internet and thinking man is there
anybody I can't just go to another
planet he's been watching too much Rick
and Morty [ __ ] yeah yeah story was
shitty tunes oh well oh well shouts out
to Manchester hopefully I get there one
day
[Music]